Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take
a look at some tips and tricks when working with lumen as well
as look at lumen visualizers. So let's get started. One of
the things you'll find out when working with a
documentation, you'll notice that we have some mentions
here that you should get set in place when working with
lumen. One of them is to turn off allow static lighting.
That one is fine. But as soon as you decide to turn off
the ambient occlusion static fraction, if you're using
quixel assets, you may run into some very dark regions where
there's light that's not being shown directly on your
objects. This is can be a little frustrating. And the
workaround for it is you would have to adjust the
parent materials AO, which is a little bit of a hassle. So
what you could do for now is you could leave this on and
still be okay, and get some good, decent results. Now that
again, if you have your own object in there, and the AO
isn't dependent on the object itself, as in it's not
being piped through the material, you should be okay
turning this off. But I just wanted to point that out
in my notes that the quixel assets, not all of them
have been updated, especially the older ones. And you
may run into some very dark areas, which will will
require you to go into the parent material and
adjust that AO system built into the material. Just
keep those things in mind. Now we're going to take a
brief look at mega lights, we're going to go into this
deeper into our atmospheric lighting course where we are
going to interactively light a scene and manage our
lights accordingly and look at the caveats for mega
lights. But here, we're just going to kind of I'm
going to point you to where you would turn them on.
And just some small notes. And from there, I'm also
going to throw some tips your way when working with
glowing objects, and so forth. Let's go and jump in
Unreal and make that happen. So in Unreal, we can go
in here and take a look at a few of our items here. And
one of them is how to set up mega lights. So if you
were to use mega lights, as it says in my notes, they're
kind of like nanites for lights, they allow you to
have multiple lights in your scene, and to be able to
manage them. Because after a while, as you have a lot of
lights in your scene, things can kind of come to a
crawl. So you got to keep those things in mind that
things can get expensive. So we're going to go under
rendering here, and we're going to scroll down just a
bit. Now you can initially turn them on here, as well
as in our post process volume, you can actually turn
them off. Also, if you don't want them shining or
working in your favor, maybe you don't need them. But
this is where you would find it under direct
lighting. Now, this mega lights doesn't really work.
Speaking of your directional light. Speaking of direct,
your directional light does not actually work at this
time when working with mega lights. And you'll see this
in the notes here. But all your other lights, it will
support. So this is an experimental feature. So keep
those things in mind. If you're working with this.
One thing I do want to mention, too, is glowing
objects. So working with your glowing objects, and we
mentioned this before, that Unreal does emissive or
works with emissive really well with lumen, it is
fantastic. Now, depending on the size, if your object is
small, you want to be able to control some of
that. And you want to you again, like I pointed in our
project settings, we can make it so that it actually
handles those small glowing objects a bit easier, if you
were to put them in your scene, and you notice that
you're getting some noise. But for good measure, it's
good to try to keep those glowing objects at a
relatively decent size. Now, these two are actually
working pretty well. They're not too small. But if you
have things such as fireflies going around, and they're,
and they're glowing, you might want to tone down that
glow just a little bit to prevent any noise or strange
blur that may occur. So just keep that in mind.
Again, in our atmospheric lighting course, we're going
to jump in a bit deeper into mega lights. And we're
going to interactively light a larger scene, as well
as a few other scenes adding some fog and a few
other items. So let's take a look at lumen visualizers
and how they work. These are basically some nice
visualizers that are put in here to give you an
actual observable output. And you can see where and
how things are being digested in your scene. Let's go
ahead and play with that in Unreal. And you'll see
there's two spots where we can actually play with
how things are being visualized here. One of them
we can have show, it'll show us our far field
traces, global traces, screen traces, and second
boundary bounces and so forth. But we also
underneath lit gives us our performance overview, as
well as our overview, and all of our different
aspects visually to see how things are being
digested in Unreal using lumen. Let's go and jump
into Unreal and take a peek at those. So in Unreal, I
can go in here under lit, and you'll see under
lumen, we have an overview. The overview is going
to give us and show us exactly how things are
being digested in our scene. The first one
showing the geometry normals, the other one
showing the reflection view with our hardware ray
tracing, and it shows that our hit lighting for
reflections is active and working. And then you
also see a lumen scene here with our surface
catch, and I'll show pink areas where
calculations getting a little rough, just a little
bit off the edge of that surface. But overall,
it's doing pretty well. And again, this gives
you just a visual representation of what's going
on under the hood. We can also go over here
and underneath our show, go to lumen, and we
can look at some of these by turning them off
in here. Like if say, I didn't want to look
at my detail traces or global traces, but I
want to look at my far field traces and my
secondary bounces, you have the option to filter
these a bit more. You'll also notice if we go
back to overview, we have a performance
overview here. And this shows us our pixel
tracing, and our dedicated reflection rays. In
green shows us our foliage, we don't have any
foliage in this particular case, or subsurface
two sided foliage that's not happening. And
then you also see max roughness, you'll see
our max foliage roughness and gives us the
number calculation for that. We're not really
working with foliage, but just kind of shows you
how things are being calculated. And you will
see the rough surfaces showing up here in our
view. And you'll see them right here as I
pulse my cursor. So rough surfaces are always
tricky when it comes to ray tracing. And when
it comes to getting that GI to work and
perform the way that we want. In earlier
versions of of Unreal ray tracing, a lot of
the times when you had a rough surface was
very difficult. And earlier versions of lumen
if you had a high rough surfaces, you would get
a lot of noise. But the noise now is
dramatically been improved greatly with unreal
when it comes to Unreal 5.5. And lumen, it
works fantastic. And there's a minimal noise
when it comes to these hires, rough surfaces.
And you can see I've cranked up the rough, a
decent amount. So you can actually see that the
noise is second, there's really hardly any at
all, just a tiny, tiny bit, which is
fantastic, a great improvement from earlier
versions of lumen.
Lumen generates an automatic parameter ization,
that's a big word of the nearby scenes surface
called the surface sketch. And it's used to
quickly look up lighting at Ray hit points in
the scene. So we can actually pop this up into
our scene and take a look at these card
placements here and see how things are going.
Now overall, for those pink areas that pop
up, you'll know the calculations can be a
little rough. And overall, ours is actually
looking pretty good with just some light
pink areas. But you'll see these rich pink
areas here can give us issues. And also in
reflections, you may get some dark areas where
the cards aren't quite working and
calculating, like they should, because
there's basically some lumen errors that are
happening on that surface catch. Let's go
and punch that in into Unreal and take a
look at that view mode. So in Unreal, I'm
going to go to my output log, and I'm
going to hit my up arrow because I have
my visualization placement cards here. I'm
gonna click on that I'm going to hit enter.
You can now see how the cards are digesting
in our scene, you will see it shift a bit as
we move around, because, well, lumen is
updating. And those calculations will be a
bit different, as I pass through different
areas, and things get occluded or darker
and so forth. That just gives you again, a
representation of how things are being
calculated. And so far, things look pretty
good in our inner reflective surfaces, there
are no black surfaces showing up, which is
really great. Let's go ahead and turn
that off. And I'm just going to hit the
upper arrow in my output log. And I'm
going to set that to zero. And we
should get back to normal. There we
go. So the areas that don't have
surface catch coverage, like I said,
these areas will not bounce light and
will appear black in your reflection. So
keep that in mind. Issues like this
can be fixed by increasing the number
of cards used with the max lumen mesh
cards. But they may not solve all
issues. So keep that in mind, make sure
your geometry is very optimized, and
that the you don't have thin pieces
of geometry, breaking the mesh up, make
sure it's modulated, those things are
going to be helpful. You'll see
there's a lumen mesh cards per task
here. But here primarily is what I'm
talking about when it comes to the
lumen mesh card amount. Let's go and
look at that quickly in Unreal. And
you can see how you can adjust those
things. So in Unreal, I can select this
simple piece of geometry, I can double
click on it, let's pull up the mesh
editor here. And I can go in here and
just simply just type in cards. And
you're going to see the max lumen
mesh cards here. Right now we can see
it's set to 12. But if for some
reason I'm getting a strange error, and
things aren't quite digesting the way
they want, I did scale this up a
little bit. Luckily, we're not getting
any issues with that. And if you
scale up a nanite object a little bit
farther than its extreme shape, which
will I'll mention later, you can run
into some issues, but we seem to work
out just fine. And this particular
case, you always want to solve those
inner DCCs when you can. But this is
where you can increase that mesh card
data for that surface catch into things
to run smoother. So again, remember to
build things modulated, do not weld
everything all at one piece, those
are going to help prevent these errors
from occurring. So let's take a look at
some tips and tricks. So lumen
reflections support more than one
bounce when hardware ray tracing is
enabled with hit lighting. So hit
lighting is very optimal and is a
good idea to set it if you're able
to support that with your card and
your system. The max reflection
bounces setting in the post process
volume is set to two or greater.
This can prevent black areas and
reflections when there is when
there is enough performance budget to
allow it. So keep those things in
mind what you're working with lumen
reflections can be used with
without lumen gi for games and
applications which use static
lighting, but wish to scale up in
reflection quality beyond reflection
captures standalone lumen reflections
only work with hardware ray tracing
is when it is enabled. And it will
enable hit lighting automatically as
lumen services catch optimization is
not available when lumen gi is
enabled. So keep those things in
mind. So the lumen hardware ray
tracing, this including enabling a
sync compute for your hardware ray
tracing by default on consoles is
available. You'll notice that the
lumen overview visualization mode
since 5.3 includes a view of
geometry normals of the lumen
scene. This is really important to
consider because they can kind of
see if things are digesting and
displaying correctly. This makes it
easier to spot your issues that
may be happening. Um, so using
nanite as much as possible, which
you're going to hear me emphasize is
very important to consider because
as your scene gets more
complicated, you'll know that it's
being rendered accurately and
you're getting the full shape of
your object at a higher
performance using nanite with
lumen and virtual shadow maps. So
lumen reflections and visualize
traces can now be used for
visualizing and debugging reflection
rays. So this is a C bar that you
can use and you can plug that in
in that console variable that you
saw me have. I pulled up the
output log and I punched it in. So
material AO updated before
5.3 was previously applied on top
of emissive and directive
lighting. So that's been updated
to not be an issue. And lumen
does not support static lighting.
So keep that in mind. Uh, and
stationary is not fully supported
right now either. So also keep
that in mind. Keep your lights
movable. So as a reminder,
source angle on directional lights
will soften your shadows and
source radius on local lights,
such as point in rec. Um, I
should say not rec, but point
and spotlight will soften your
shadows. Note the difference
reminder software ray tracing
mode controls which tracing
method lumen uses when ray
tracing the scene detail tracing
traces against individual meshes
distance fields for highest
quality global tracing traces
against the lower detail global
distance fields for fastest
traces. So support hardware
ray tracing this. You really
want to make sure you turn that
on. If it's available, this is
going to allow you to have a
better visual fidelity for your
scene and geometry limitations.
Again, keep those pieces of
geometry separate and you want
to make sure in your foliage
that you set things to affect
distance field lighting. Also, I
want to mention when you're
inheriting an older scene,
double check in your project
settings that mesh distance
fields are active by default in
the newer versions of unreal
that should be on. But if you're
getting a new older scene, you
may want to go back and check
that out. Well, that's it for
this topic. Hopefully you
enjoyed and enjoyed it and it
actually made sense to you and
can help you out. Here's a
link in our slides here that
shows you where you can further
grab some more knowledge. In the
next video, we're going to
take a look at Nanite and
virtual shadow maps and how to
manage those and how they work
with the whole lumen system.
Thanks again.